-Our next guest
is a Grammy and Academy
Award-winning producer,
songwriter, and deejay.
The second season
of his podcast,
"The FADER Uncovered,"
is available now.
Please welcome to the show
Mark Ronson, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show.
How are you?
-I'm great.
-It -- It's lovely to see you.
And I want to start
by congratulating you.
Recently married. There you go.
-Yes.
-There's you and your wife,
Grace Gummer.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, it's -- it's --
It was wonderful.
She's the best ever.
I don't -- I can't say enough.
And it was --
it was a wonderful day.
-It was a great wedding.
And I would imagine a little bit
scaled back because we are,
of course, in the middle
of a pandemic, but --
-Yes.
-I'm curious.
With someone like you who is
a famous music producer
and deejay, do you have a band,
do you have a deejay?
Or is it just too much pressure
to put on someone else?
-Well, I --
Weirdly, like, I hate deejays.
It's so strange
because I am a deejay,
and I was thinking like,
"Who would I have?"
And then I thought,
"Well, it's not fair,
that just 'cause
I don't like deejays..."
Everyone else
should be able to dance.
But a bunch of the guys
in the band
that were going to play
are some of my friends
who play in the Roots
and play on "Jimmy Fallon."
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-And -- Yes.
-Yeah, it's very --
-Amazing, too.
-Very nice pool
for a wedding band.
-They are great, and they were
also playing earlier that week.
Remember -- Barack Obama
was having his huge 60th.
-Yes, I do believe there
was some press about that.
-There was some press
about that. Of course.
So -- So -- And, you know,
as we're scaling back
our wedding
because it's COVID
and we're kind of looking at --
I mean, I can't believe
I'm, like, judging my wedding
against, like, Obama's 60th.
Remember like, through the week,
it was like --
well, now they've disinvited
200 people
and now it's only gonna be 50.
And so we had --
we disinvited everybody
at our wedding except,
you know, immediate family.
So when the guys got there
from the Roots band,
I kind of wanted to be like,
"So what was the Obama --
it was really small, right?"
They were like "No.
That's -- It was wild.
It was, like, crazy."
And I was just like -- Like,
they hadn't slept in three days.
They've probably
been jamming with, like,
Quincy Jones and Dave Chappelle.
Like, "Whatever."
And I'm like, "Okay, well,
just play the jazz tunes."
Like -- Like, "I'm sorry.
This isn't going to be that."
I think it was a good, like,
hungover Sunday for them.
-Very nice. Good -- Good vibe.
-You have -- You have a podcast
where you interview musicians.
You have a documentary series
on Apple TV
called "Watch the Sound."
The same sort of idea.
-Yes.
-When you were talking
to musicians --
And obviously
it's what you do for a living.
But a lot of these people,
you were listening
to their music
before it was your living.
-Yes.
-How do you separate
those moments
of being someone who is,
you know,
in their field, a peer,
but also a giant fan
of their work?
-I mean, it's impossible.
I just, like, sit on my hands.
And I'm like,
"Don't be an idiot."
No. I mean, it's true.
I make music, and it's nice
that some of these people
think of me as a peer, like --
But I'm talking to Big Boi
from "Outkast."
My favorite concert ever
was Outkast in 1999 in Miami.
And just, like, these are people
that have soundtracked my life.
So I always try
and wait the moment.
Because you don't want
to start up
and you're like,
"Der, I love you."
'Cause then it just seems like
you're trying to win them over.
I don't know. But --
And then, occasionally,
I'll interview some rapper
who's, like,
a young up-and-coming person
like Rico Nasty.
And at the very end,
she'll be like,
"So, like, what do you do?
You're like a journalist
or something?"
Like, she has -- she has no idea
I make music,
which is also great.
So I kind of -- I --
I don't mind either way.
-I would imagine, like,
interviewing someone
is one thing, but you also
collaborate with them.
And that, it must be even
more important not to
sort of geek out or --
or be a fanboy,
because then they might not
take you seriously.
-Yeah. I mean, I think that --
I mean, the ultimate example,
of course,
of working with, like,
somebody who is, like,
basically a god is, like,
Paul McCartney.
And I feel like on day one,
you're allowed to be an idiot.
And like -- I've been producing
records for like 15 years.
It was like everything
was Kryptonite in my hands.
Like, it's Paul McCartney,
you know?
-Yeah.
-So then I think he gives you
a day to be like that
because he's used to --
He has that effect on everyone.
But then, like, day two, like,
"You better come
with the heat, bro,
or Sir Paul is gonna fire you."
So -- So, yeah.
So it's just about
getting over those things.
But, like, Q-Tip,
Ghostface Killah,
all these people I grew up with
who were like --
grew up listening
to their music,
when you're finally
in the studio with them,
it is kind of surreal, you know?
-I can only imagine.
You -- You've worked
with people like Amy Winehouse
and Lady Gaga and Bruno Mars.
And I'm just wondering,
over the course of this career
where you've worked with this,
you know,
diverse slate
of singers and musicians,
are there moments where you hear
a lyric for the first time
or you hear, you know,
a note for the first time
that, even having worked
in this for so long,
that you're just taken aback
and in awe?
-Yeah, like,
I definitely remember
when we were writing "Shallow"
and you're futzing around
and everybody's
got an instrument
and going through chords and --
And Lady Gaga,
she's playing this piano.
And the moment --
She's looking for words.
She's saying phrases.
And then she says --
She sang,
"Tell me something, boy,"
or "Tell me something, girl.
Are you happy
in this modern world?"
And, like, the way she sang it
and her voice,
like, your hairs just stand up.
You're like, "Okay.
What's the next line?"
Then you --
Then you get this excitement.
But, yeah. No.
It's -- It's amazing
when those moments happen.
-I feel like, thanks to a number
of music documentaries
over the last,
you know, decade-plus,
we have a greater appreciation
for what a music producer does.
And you just realize
there's such a delicate
fiddling and changing and --
you know, deciding, you know,
what to bring up
and what to bring down.
Do you ever hear
one of your songs years later
and regret choices
you made or...?
-Yeah.
Like, I listen to all of them,
and I'm just like --
I don't listen to my own music,
like, active--
That's not true. I just...
-[ Laughter ]
No -- No, I -- I don't.
I don't make it a regular thing.
But, occasionally, like,
you hear a song and it's, like,
something you did 15 years ago,
and you're like,
"Oh, I get it. I was, like,
this aggressive kid.
I was trying to throw
the whole kitchen sink.
Now I know why I should have,
like, chilled out."
But, occasionally, like --
I was in the airport, actually.
And I heard this song playing,
like, far -- from the speaker.
Like, some duty-free.
I was in the whiskey store
at 7:00 in the morning.
No. Heathrow. Sorry.
And I was like,
"Oh, that's cool."
I was like,
"Those drums sound cool."
Because I always hear drums, and
if the drums have a good sound,
I, like,
want to hear the song.
And I ended up Shazaming it,
and I looked,
and I was like,
"Oh, I made that."
Like, I --
[ Laughter ]
It wasn't so amazing, but I was
like, "That's so funny."
I was like, "I wonder who did
the drums on this song."
And I forgot
that I had done that song.
-I really -- I mean, that's --
that's really funny.
Like, "This is really great.
I got to --
Oh. Oh, well. Look at that.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
One bottle of Jack Daniels.
Thank you.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
Congrats on the podcast.
Can't wait to see the show.
-Thank you.
-Mark Ronson.
"The FADER Uncovered"
is available wherever
you get your podcasts.
And "Watch the Sound"
is streaming on Apple TV+.